[Musique]
je vous présente ma femme colette vous
avez épousé un écu à l'appel tu as
épousé une petite paysanne sens ce sont
deux poules
j'ai eu une idée remarquable
vous pourriez écrit pour moi les
histoires que l'on m'avait raconté mes
années d'écolière oui ce serait mon
nouveau roman
je m'appelle claudine jab x continue
probablement je ne mourrai pas déjà
parvenu à faire de vous sont maigres
c'est tout c'est trop féminin plus de
piquant mois littérature c'est le plus
grand succès que nous ayons connue à ce
jour
savez vous qu'il achète les jeunes
filles 1
c'est un phénomène le tout-paris dit que
ton mari est un ges madame colette j'ai
cru comprendre que willy s'était inspiré
de vos années d'écolière en effet j'ai
eu le loisir d'apporter ma contribution
vous avez très important
ces jeunes filles vous leur avez donné
une voix quelqu'un vous l'a dit
et n'est-il de l'apprendre par d'autres
vous rencontrez m'a suffi
il vous tourner autour jalousie est mal
placée c'est sa femme qui m'intéresse
c'est trop risqué
depuis quand considères-tu le scandale
comme une chose à éviter
bonté divine mais que portait vollard
le nouveau claudine pourquoi ne pas le
publier sous nos deux noms c'est hors de
question je veux mon nom sur leur
amenons nous tenons quelque chose
d'explosif
si la situation nous échappe nous
risquons de sombrer tous les deux
écrivez
[Musique]
tu fais du mal du mal et du mal et tu
crois qu'en proclamant que tous les
hommes le français se disent que tout
mes réflexions
mais ces motions ou nourrices et rendre
tout ça c'était moi
quand tu m'as trouvé je ne savais rien
[Musique]
tu m'as façon excellente est désir
menez qui croyaient que jamais je ne
briserait mais chaîne eh bien tu attends
détruit brûlé
je m'appelle commerce
c'est la main qui tient la plume qui
écrit l'histoire